I didn't know dr. King but what he did
and what he did for me and what he did
for us changed my life I came into the
army at a time when segregation was
still in the land although the army had
integrated but we had this dichotomy
between being on an army post where I
was open and being in Columbus Georgia
where I was prejudiced where people
threw me out of a hamburger joint after
I came back from my first tour in
Vietnam and had been injured and all I
wanted was a hammer and they wouldn't
serve me but it was dr. King and his
efforts beginning from the 1955 period
the Montgomery bus boycott all the way
through his death in 1968 it was his
efforts that not only freed blacks it
freely freed Americans and freed whites
it took a burden off the white people of
the United States and took a burden off
the black people so it was something he
did for all of America and that's what
made his contribution is so significant
and even though I couldn't participate
in that because I was an active duty
officer going to Vietnam twice during
that period and also serving elsewhere I
followed it every time I went to Vietnam
I left my wife and infant children back
in Birmingham Alabama and in 1963
Birmingham Alabama was not a very nice
place at riots Bull Connor and his dogs
and my father-in-law spent his time
guarding my family while I was in
Vietnam serving the nation and all that
changed now dr. King's legacy is a real
one we've got a lot more to do without a
long way to go but I'm sitting areas and
son of an immigrant family a black kid
public school education was able to rise
to the top and the way that was made for
me was built a large extent by what dr.
Cain did and by his great sacrifice when
he was murdered on April 4th 1968 I was
at Fort Leavenworth Kansas in training
getting ready to go back to Vietnam I'll
never forget the shock that went through
our community and I'll never forget the
image of buses being put around the
White House bumper to bumper
check the White House from the outraged
citizens in Washington DC and so he will
never be forgotten the only thing I was
able to do later in life was to be on a
Council that helped build a new monument
to dr. King but he had an indelible
impression upon America and he should
always be treasured for that and we
should all pause and reflect on the
contributions he's made on this 50th
anniversary of his passing it's hard to
tell what the next 50 years will be like
because I couldn't tell you 50 years ago
what today would be like we've done
thinkable for me to become chairman of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff or Secretary
of State but the trend I see is that
America is becoming a more mosaic nation
by that I mean you see in two marriages
you see tolerance of marriages that you
would not have seen to be tolerance as
years ago so I think America by the Year
2043 will find that the minorities of
Americans are now the majority of
Americans and we're the only nation in
the world who could handle this kind of
demographic change and I'm confident as
I watch television and kind of don't pay
attention to the wild stuff that said
the watch television more and more I see
acceptance of this kind of change in a
demographics and I hope that 50 years
from now we will all be again one people
one nation one nation under God as our
founding fathers told us we should be
and that is my hope and I think that's
dr. King's hope if he was so alive he
would be beating up everybody to do the
right thing he would not have given up
remember he died just after going to the
service of garbage men in Memphis the
whole nation was carrying the burden of
discrimination and Jim Crow ISM it was
holding blacks down but it's also
holding whites down they knew better
they knew this was wrong they knew that
the Emancipation Proclamation and
Abraham Lincoln what he did the Civil
War they knew that was the way to go but
for many years after that throughout the
rest of that century blacks were again
subjected there was slaves once again
even if there was not legal slavery
and so the story I always like to tell
is the hamburger joint I got thrown out
of after I came back from Vietnam was
looking for a place for my family to
live I just went in for hamburger I knew
I was in a segregated City and she
wouldn't serve me but I went back to
that same hamburger joint on July 4th
1964 right after the civil rights
accommodation Act had been signed and I
asked my hamburger and they said yes sir
and they handed me my hamburger she
didn't want to discriminate against me
and we removed that burden off of her I
could go into a store now and try and
close all the signs that used to exist
all over the south anywhere below
Washington DC would have three signs
over the three restrooms in a gas
station black and then white men white
women blacks going all going you
couldn't find any of those in the
country now and so they were suffering
too there's still some of them who think
well we should go a little bit backwards
no we're going to keep going forward but
it's a challenge and it's a struggle and
all of us have to fight this struggle to
make sure that all of our fellow
citizens not just blacks but Indians
Hispanics and anybody else you can think
of is treated equally and gets just
results from their work their education
and their belief in this great country
of ours I think we've come a long way
but we've got a long way to go
we see everyday problems that exists in
our country but at the same time I see
great things that have happened in our
country I see a black mayor in Plano
Texas something you never would have
thought would happen I've seen
immigrants rising to top positions I see
people of color who are very very
wealthy in the stock market
I see people of color and different
backgrounds different different sources
of their coming to the United States
doing very very well I'm moving up so
you can't say that it's all the failure
what it has been is great success but
success doesn't end you have to keep
going after it you have to keep finding
where the problems are where the
discrimination is and doing something
about it and when I think dr. King will
be focusing on right now is the people
who are the poorest in our land
who do not have the education they need
who are not living in the kind of family
units that they really need and who need
jobs ultimately the solution to all
problems associated with our nation I
think is to get everybody an education
and a job and put them in a family unit
that can bring the children up raise the
children and teach children how to mind
their manners and mind their adults and
that's what it's all about